[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est considéré comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département a c'est parti pour le
sommaire un football la coupe du monde a
débuté depuis jeudi dernier les
supporters ont déjà commencé à vibrer
dans les yvelines au rythme de l'équipe
de france et des autres sélections
nationales
nous avons rencontré des supporters
tricolores et or thulliez les détails
dans ce magazine vtt la revanche est
fêté ce dimanche sa 20e édition sur la
colline d'elancourt 150 participants se
sont affrontés sur ce site qui
accueillera les jeux olympiques en 2024
reportage à suivre golf des animations
ludiques qui était programmé ce samedi à
montigny le bretonneux
objectif faire découvrir le monde de la
petite balle blanche et de la ryder cup
au grand public coup de projecteur dans
ce magazine l'actualité sportive de la
semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par du football plus de
13 millions de téléspectateurs ont
regardé le match france australie ce
samedi midi dans l'hexagone dans les
bars de 50 ans olivier on a également
vibré au rythme des bleus ils étaient
plusieurs dizaines à voir exulté au coup
de sifflet final dans cet établissement
situé près du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines victoire 2 1
de la france face à l'australie on
écoute les réactions à la fin du match
une victoire c'est plus important après
dans le jeu beaucoup de choses à revoir
à ce premier match a été très très
stressant pour les supporters
j'imagine que les joueurs sur le terrain
aussi parce que il ya eu très peu
d'occasions de marquer malgré que
l'équipe australienne était pas très
très forte à s'était pas très bien
pauvre bête est pas très bon mais on a
kiffé comme le but le prochain match de
l'équipe de france est programmée ce
jeudi à 17h contre le pérou la france ne
sera pas la seule équipe soutenue par
les yvelinois pendant cette coupe du
monde de football le département devrait
également vibré au rythme des exploits
du portugal après leur victoire à l'euro
2016 en finale contre la france les
lusitaniens espère une nouvelle fois
aller jusqu'à là la finale avec leurs
stars le quintuple ballon d'or cristiano
ronaldo déjà buteur à trois reprises
contre l'espagne vont envoyer dernier un
montage de jules ogre la ville la star
de cette maison plaisir ouah c'est lui
cristiano ronaldo tom et williams 8 et
11 ans deux frères d'origine portugaise
ont de grands fans de l'attaquant
lisboète et de son équipe nationale
l'asi ses crampons l'avait l'année
dernière là c'est quand ils tiraient des
coups francs et year for lack wyman les
accélérations avec la balle il a quoi
une règle la scène les actualités c'est
ça au ballon d'or qu'elle a gagné cette
année vous ressemblez au portugal la
passion ne s'arrête pas qu'aux posters
et olives les deux jeunes passent
également près d'une heure par jour à
regarder des vidéos des exploits du
portugal et de leur idole
et quand ils allument la console de jeu
le portugal est évidemment leur premier
choix parce qu'ils sont forts et ronaldo
las préfet
des grosses frappes et aiderez il fait
une très très vite
pendant la coupe du monde en russie les
deux frères ont fait leur choix ils
supporteront l'équipe nationale
portugaise une décision qui ravit leur
mère je suis contente parce que c'est
vrai que moi c'est mes origines et je
trouve ça bien que les enfants s'en
rappelle est en tout cas enfin le
supporte le portugal dans tout parce que
c'est dans le foot mais c'est aussi
c'est aussi pour plein d'autres choses
ils veulent tout le temps les là bas en
vacances et adorent ils veulent y vivre
sur les terrains de football yvelinois
les coéquipiers de cristiano ronaldo
également des supporters depuis sa
création en 1972 le club des portugais
de plaisir vibre au rythme des exploits
des lusitaniens et non de l'équipe de
france y en a certains qui sont pour les
deux moi je suis pour les deux j'habite
en france et voilà
notre famille portugaise on a du sens
portier on sera toujours derrière le
portugal quoi c'est comme la plupart des
personnes qu'ils ont double nationalité
on a grandi ici
nos parents sont portugais ont fait nos
vacances au portugal donc voilà c'est le
portugal a des qui a amassé le portugal
avant tout pour vivre cette coupe du
monde le club a prévu d'organiser des
repas devant la télévision les soirs de
matches du portugal mais ils ne
devraient pas être les seuls à suivre
les rencontres dans le secteur très
grosse communauté surtout un plaisir les
clés et villepreux
il ya une grosse communauté portugaise
donc je pense que
les veilles de matches vous les sentez
mal fait et moi tout ça ou dans les
cafés ou g13 garder les mangera plus
personne doha avec plus de 4000
habitants d'origine portugaise dans les
yvelines le département sera forcément
partagé entre le bleu et le vert et
rouge pendant cette coupe du monde
un mot de vtt à présent la discipline
était à l'honneur ce week-end sur la
colline à del en cours sur le site des
futures épreuves de vtt aux jo de 2024
des centaines de coureurs ont souffert
sur la 20e édition de la arvant chardin
montage de sandrine fonds taille des
images de nicolas landry la revanche est
fêté son 20e anniversaire ce dimanche 17
juin 151 coureurs ont participé à cette
édition 2010 8 sur la colline
d'elancourt cinq fois plus que lors de
la première édition imaginé en 1998
temps les organisateurs
bah c'est une tradition c'est c'est
l'histoire de saint quentin en yvelines
l'histoire de cette colline ce site
il était à l'abandon et accueil vraiment
nous notre club qui utilisons site de à
koungheul en cours et quand on pense
qu'on va y avoir les jeux olympiques je
pense que on a mis une petite pierre à
l'édifice pour que je sois ici quoi
depuis 20 ans le parcours a peu évolué
pour cette édition 2010 8 un tracé
technique a été dessiné sur le point
culminant de l'île de france avec ses
231 m honte la grosse but qui fait très
mal aux jambes
et maintenant ça devient de plus en plus
dur voilà parce qu'elle est très raide
et il ya il n'y a pas du tout du tout 2
mais on peut on peut pas du tout
récupérer c'est hyper dur c'est
extrêmement extrêmement dur il faut
trouver un bon rythme car direct une
fois qu'on est on est parti on qu'on a
passé le sommet quand lakota revient on
est déjà chaud et ça ça va déjà mieux
au bout de l'effort c'est geoffroy le
turc qui remporte cette 20e édition pour
sa première participation à l'épreuve
derrière moi il y avait de deux
concurrents et j'ai décidé la quête
d'attaqués dans une bosse directement
dès le premier tour pour pour être
tranquille après au final ça s'est super
bien passé j'ai creusé l'écart au fil
des tours et et puis voilà je finis en
tête et c'est cool cette épreuve a
également permis comme chaque année de
récolter des dons pour les orphelins des
sapeurs pompiers de france
au total 3000 euros ont été reversés à
l'association
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
21e édition du handball à présent dans
son match de barrage pour l'accession à
la nationale 2 plaisir s'est finalement
incliné la semaine dernière sur terrain
le ton contre molsheim après avoir mené
la partie pendant plus de 40 minutes
score final 27 26 les événements
resteront donc en nationale 3 l'année
prochaine pour avoir après avoir terminé
deuxième du championnat pour nous parler
de ce match nous recevons sur ce plateau
à l'eau à arlon chastre pivot de
l'équipe benjamins à modeste le demi
centre maxime arima son pivot et
l'ailier alexandre constants bonsoir
messieurs
alors est-ce que vous avez décompresser
après ça match encore la pilule voilà on
s'est pris au jeu et
arrivé au match de barrage on ya
vraiment cru et sur le terrain on ya cru
parce qu'on a vraiment dominé cette
équipe de molsheim et malheureusement
sur le money time
ça tourne pas en notre faveur le
scénario du coup qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de ce scénario était
prévisible
imprévisible ce scénario de toute façon
sur un match tout peut se passer après
nous on ya cru on a joué nos chances dès
le début et c'est ce qui c'est on a vu
le déroulé du match pendant les dix
premières minutes monde est montée à
plus 4 5 après on est s'est un peu
effondré on est un petit temps faibles
ils sont venus on en est resté devant à
la mi-temps on a réussi à gérer les
temps faibles mais pas jusqu'à la fin du
match et c'est pour ça peut-être que ça
on est passé derrière sur la fin avec
100 euros constants est ce que ce
finalement ce scénario était prévisible
avant de commencer le match est ce que
vous attendiez à mettre autant en
difficulté cette équipe est bien dans
tous les cas on
on s'est préparés a livré le meilleur
match de la saison donc c'était notre
meilleur match
un des meilleurs en tout cas on ya mis
l'envié
dans tous les cas c'est la pilule est
dure à avaler mais le meilleur a été
faite de l'autre côté on a fait le
travail
même si à l'arrivée le résultat n'est
pas n'est pas en notre faveur
maxime vous allez un petit peu parlé
entre vous à la sortie de la rencontre
quelle était l'atmosphère dans le
vestiaire fin du match forcément
compliqué compliqué tout le monde est
déçu quelques pleurs pour certains
joueurs donc à dire pour les plus
anciens on est allé les réconforter
après il y en a qui sont remis plus ou
moins vite du match mais dans l'ensemble
on a quand même fait un gros match et il
fallait essayer de positiver quand même
après après 7,7 des fêtes
et puis bon le soir on était tous
ensemble façon ça a été notre force
cette saison c'est la cohésion de
l'équipe
du coup le soir on a essayé de un peu
oublié et puis et puis
à l'année prochaine si je comprends bien
il ya quand même quelques regrets quand
même sur cère forcément forcément quand
on finit deuxième est que après une
saison où il ya eu il ya eu des hauts il
ya eu quelques bas aussi mais quand on
termine 2ème ce qu'on a envie c'est de
cette passer ce tour et est allé en
nationale 2 pour voir ce que ça donne
alors je crois savoir un charmant
modeste que le coach victor guerrier qui
n'a pas pu être présent ce soir sur ce
plateau a piqué une grosse colère à la
sortie du match
je crois qu'ils ne vous a quasiment pas
parlé il a piqué une grosse colère mais
c'était pas à l'encontre de ses joueurs
donc c'est pas envers nous pour avoir
parlé avec lui un peu après le match à
froid ils étaient fiers de nous et
la colère c'est plus porté sur le corps
arbitral qui qui selon lui et selon
plusieurs joueurs n'ont pas arbitré dans
le même sens en deuxième mi-temps
surtout sur des décisions qui était
identique des deux côtés on avait plus
facilement des 2 minutes et 17 m contre
nous alors que de l'autre côté sur la
même action de 3 fois par exemple sur
arnaud on revenait sur 1,9 m s'était pas
sanctionné donc c'est ça qui est
frustrant parce que quand ça se joue à
dix buts c'est pas très grave mais quand
c'est sur des matches couperets qui se
joue à un but c'est ça qui est difficile
alors vous terminez quand même à une
très belle il faut dire deuxième place
en étant promu est ce que voilà est-ce
qu'on peut être satisfait de cette
saison
moi personnellement je suis ultra
satisfait pourquoi parce que
l'intersaison était compliquée avec
plusieurs départs de nos cadres on a été
recruté deux trois joueurs de qualité
dont arnaud james le gardien et surtout
des joueurs qui étaient présents au club
comme max qui joue en équipe réserve et
qui aujourd'hui s'est imposé avec nous
en équipe première et des jeunes qui
poussent tels alexandre joachim qui qui
font une très très belle saison et on
voit qu'on peut s'appuyer sur la
formation plaisir oise et ça c'est très
plaisant et pour l'avenir c'est observer
de profitable alors est-ce que vous avez
imaginé en début de saison est ce que
vous aviez imaginé en début de saison
pouvoir terminer à cette deuxième place
pouvoir avoir treize victoires 1 nul
pour seulement 8 défaites
on est en promo franchement je vais s'il
avait été ou est on en a discuté à 8
heures dès le début de la saison il y
avait peu de personnes qui avaient
imaginé ça qui y croyaient néanmoins
l'objectif initial c'était le maintien
il faut le dire ça dépend pour qui
il y avait vraiment des gens qui pour
qui dans leur tête c'était la montée et
jouée les
la première place est la deuxième
puisque vraiment le discours était des
débuts de dire dans cette poule tout
tout tout va se passer
tout le monde va battre tout le monde et
au final quand on regarde la fin de la
saison c'est ce qui s'est passé il ya eu
des victoires dans tous les sens nous on
a fait match nul contre le dernier sur
la dernière journée de championnat
les premiers ont perdu un peu partout
aussi donc
eh bien c'est ce qui s'est produit c'est
ce qu'on avait prévu et au final il ya
des gens qui croyaient dès le début de
la saison j'en faisais partie y en avait
d'autres
après on a loupé la montée c'est la
seule chose qu'on retient la fin de la
saison alexandre qui responsables de
cette bonne saison
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qu'il faut
mettre en avant l'effectif complète à
mettre en avant sur cette saison c'est
vrai qu'avec les nombreux blessés
qu'on a eu au cours de cette saison
c'était dur de faire avec et on a su
trouver notre force dans la cohésion
d'équipé qu'on la dit maxime maxime tout
à l'heure et c'est ce qui nous a permis
de nous maintenir à ce niveau là dans
cette fin de saison qui a été
déterminante pour notre part notre suite
maxime dans quel secteur vous devez vous
renforcez parce que je suppose que vous
devez quand même vous renforcer pour la
saison prochaine
ouais il ya quelques heures comme l'a
dit comme l'a dit alexandre on a eu
plusieurs blessés donc je sais pas si
c'est dans un secteur mais ce serait
peut-être plus haut niveau quantitatif
qu'on devrait se renforcer
et après collectivement on a été bon est
ce qu'il faudrait pas avoir de temps en
temps pour débloquer quelques situations
les plus fortes individualités donc à
chercher après se renforcer si la saison
prochaine on fait la même saison avec
peut-être un une ou deux victoires de
plus ça nous permettra peut-être d'être
premier est monté benjamin vous serez
tous là la saison prochaine
vous avez discuté avec les autres
joueurs à discuter j'ai entendu personne
dire qu'il allait partir je pense que
l'étape présents ici vont rester après
on sait jamais en période de mercato
c'est quand même
mais après une saison pareille je vois
je vois pas des joueurs des joueurs
partir peut-être un ou deux d'un point
de vue professionnel ou autre mais d'un
point de vue sportif je vois pas
quelqu'un partir aujourd'hui du plaisir
de bakker après cette saison il y aura
que des joueurs qui vont arriver sur
vous pour moi oui qui vont apporter un
plus à l'effectif après il faut pas faux
pas qui est 12 joueurs car et parce que
ça fonctionnera pas il faut vraiment
deux trois à quatre crus maximum qui
s'intègre au collectif et notre façon de
faire aujourd'hui et qui nous apporte un
vrai un vrai apport en balistique pour
nous aider à gravir cette petite marge
qui nous a manqué cette année alors nos
chastes qui a peut-être un un piège à
éviter la saison prochaine un piège dans
lequel vous êtes tombé cette année qu'il
ne faudra pas reproduire les prochaines
mais déjà les équipes qu'on va vous on
va affronter sont différentes
donc il faudra s'adapter à leur jeu de
la seule premier de l'après choses et
après il faudra pas faudra rester sur la
même dynamique et ça ça va être un peu
compliqué parce qu'on finit finalement
la saison sur une frustration et sur une
défaite qui coûte cher donc faudra
oublier cette fin de saison et repartir
sur quelque chose de positif dès le
début ça commence par balle en ce moment
la fin de saison avec les recrutements
présent à l'entraînement pour les
personnes qui viennent faire des essais
et surtout dès la reprise pour reprendre
tous ensemble le groupe est formé
quelque chose de nouveau pour une
nouvelle aventure
merci à tous les quatre d'être passé sur
ce plateau on continue à suivre avec
attention vos performances la saison
prochaine en nationale 3 encore bravo
pour votre parcours nous allons
maintenant prendre le large dans ce
magazine direction l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines ce week-end la
coupe nationale les entreprises étaient
organisées sur l'un des plus grands
plans d'eau d'île de france avec ses 200
hectares et la bataille a été acharnée
des images de nicolas landry avantages
jusqu'en 2000
une véritable bataille navale
interentreprises s'est déroulée ce
samedi 16 et dimanche 17 juin sur l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
la coupe nationale était programmé pour
la dixième fois sur le site
objectif travailler en équipe le
principe de la course ce n'est pas de
gagner la course c'est d'éviter que son
camarade soit dernier donc c'est
applique les principes à la fois 2
solidarité et de l'application des
règles de course puisque dans ce jeu-là
rails
je cours c'est extrêmement important au
total une vingtaine d'entreprises venus
de toute la france regroupant soixante
participants se sont inscrits toutes ont
leur technique pour dompter les bateaux
de 16 pieds remporter la victoire
déjà bien navigué proprement pas faire
d'erreur et puis surveiller le vent les
êtres premier être devant c'est toujours
indispensable car le plan d'eau qui est
un peu particulier où donc là il était
situé au vent d'ouest donc c'est dans la
relaxe du des plans d'eau il faut faire
très attention la rangée d'arbres qui
est tout au fond sur le plan d'eau et de
ya plein de déventer et ben voilà donc
un petit stratégie quand même dans
l'ensemble comme les participants auront
une nouvelle occasion de s'illustrer
l'année prochaine une nouvelle édition
déjà programmés sur le plan d'eau de 200
hectares on reste sur l'eau pour parler
d'aviron le versailles et à thomas bach
ou que participera le week-end prochain
la deuxième manche de la coupe du monde
à linz en autriche le médaillé de bronze
à rio sera associé à pierre roux 1 pour
la première fois en deux de couple poids
léger à objectif terminer sur le podium
au total 21 embarcations sont engagés
dans cette catégorie parmi lesquels on
retrouvera des belges des italiens des
norvégiens des polonais qui seront les
plus sérieux concurrents défoncer les
finales sont programmées ce dimanche on
continue à parler à de versailles
journée olympique était organisée
vendredi dernier au stade au mob auront
plus de 350 jeunes de cm1 cm2 ont pu
s'essayer pendant toute la journée au
saut en longueur au sprint au golf et
est également au pentathlon moderne
l'occasion de découvrir certaines
disciplines à montage signé xavier
jaglin
les enfants donner le meilleur
d'eux-mêmes ce vendredi 13 juin pour la
journée olympique le rendez vous
organisé au stade maubon de versailles a
réuni plus de 350 jeunes de cm1 cm2 de
la commune
l'occasion de découvrir de nouvelles
disciplines c'est pas dur d'apprendre
s'adapter très facilement justement plus
on commence tôt et plus c'est facile
donc la non ils ont des réelles
capacités d'adaptation
on détecte un peu des jeunes les
qualités biais les qualités dans
l'impulsion les enfants ont pu également
s'essayer au pentathlon moderne une
épreuve composée de cinq disciplines
dont le tir au pistolet qui s'organisait
à versailles pendant les jeux de paris
2024 après quelques essais à premier
verdict eh bien on s'amuse
c'est nous emmène dans la cible tout le
monde est content les élèves
l'enseignante j'ai essayé aussi c'est
loin d'être facile
la concentration
savoir modérer son enthousiasme c'est
très bien avec ces tests les
organisateurs espèrent susciter des
vocations chez les plus jeunes
versailles et objectif c'est évidemment
de l'est de les orienter vers cette
discipline pour pourquoi pas créer un
club à versailles et être vraiment dans
la course pour les pour les jeux
olympiques pour être dans la course pour
les jo versailles devraient de nouveau
organiser cette journée olympique tous
les ans jusqu'en 2024 du golfe à présent
à son jour de l'organisation de la ryder
cup à saint quentin en yvelines les
yvelinois ont pu s'essayer au golf
pendant la golf expérience samedi à
montigny le bretonneux
le rendez vous proposés au grand public
de découvrir la discipline et
d'approcher le trophée de la compétition
des images de nicolas landry alors vous
avez vu vous avez arrêté votre club vous
l'avait arrêté après la frappe
non laissez le partir jouer le geste
n'est pas encore parfait jacob seul
arrive venus découvrir ce samedi 16 juin
les bases du golfe à montigny le
bretonneux pendant la golf expérience
une première pour cet hymne est mon
temps c'est plus simple quand on regarde
à la télé et on se dit que c'est plutôt
facile à ces techniques d'une pensée la
position c'est le fait donc de viser
juste pas taper trop fort comme jacob
s'ils sont plusieurs milliers à être
venus découvrir le monde de la petite
balle blanche sur le quai françois
truffaut petit surdimensionné practice
sur l'eau tous ont pu s'essayer au golf
de façon ludique
bah là c'était dur aussi parce qu'il
fallait
ça va faire du bien j'ai ça a l'air de
bien lui plaire quoi après peut-être que
ça va faire appel
culture tiger woods de bon on verra en
parallèle l'événement organisé par saint
quentin en yvelines avait également pour
objectif de faire découvrir la ryder cup
au grand public
l'épreuve sera organisé du 28 au 30
septembre golf national et devrait être
suivi par plus de 750 millions de
téléspectateurs alors les gens
évidemment sont de plus en plus au
courant qu'ils à la ryder cup dans 100
jours donc on est très fier ça veut dire
que notre travail de sensibilisation à
fonctionner mais il y en a encore qui
découvre et qui découvrait même le golfe
après la golf expérience look et
françois truffaut de montigny le
bretonneux se transformera fin septembre
une gigantesque fête zone pendant la
ryder cup
les matchs seront diffusés gratuitement
pendant l'épreuve on continue à parler
de golf et de la ryder cup comme chaque
lundi tv 68 vous propose de vous
immerger dès à présent dans la
compétition et de découvrir chaque
semaine des anecdotes sportif sur le
tournoi
aujourd'hui christophe muniesa le dtn de
la fédération française de golf nous
livre l'un de ses souvenirs regarder
[Musique]
2004 c'est une ryder cup dont je me
souviens à plus d'un titre
compte tenu du fait que sur le papier
l'équipe américaine était vraiment
meilleur
encore une fois avec ses ténors ou d'en
tête et mikkelson en tête aux côtés de
une épreuve très très solide
alliant expérience et puis aussi
quelques oeufs young gods et pour autant
des choix d'associations dans notamment
les doubles puisque tiger woods avait
été associé à phil mikelson en double il
n'avait jamais joué ensemble en ryder
cup
donc en termes d'affichage c'était
extrêmement impressionnant pour autant
ils se sont effacées contre la paire
européenne à laquelle il était opposé
démontrant le savoir faire d'un côté de
l'équipe européenne dans sa capacité à
créer des équipes et à faire feu de tout
bois en toute circonstance alors que les
américains bénéficié d'une équipe sur le
papier a priori plus forte et pour
autant on les qualifier à l'époque d'
équipe d'aéroport les joueurs qui
pourtant joué le pitch et tour toute
l'année côte à côte ne réussissait pas à
créer cette véritable dynamique d'équipé
donc cette ryder cup aussi perdu par les
américains en 2004
ça a été le début d'une nouvelle
dynamique pour l'équipe américaine qui a
par la suite chercher véritablement à
développer un esprit d équipe organisée
des rencontres entre les joueurs à
différentes occasions pendant l'année
pour essayer de cimenter cette équipe et
d'enfin être en capacité est bien
d'offrir une véritable résistance à
l'équipe européenne alors ça n'aura pas
été le cas deux ans après en europe
hockey club mais en revanche quant à la
ryder cup est retourné sur le sol
américain
en 2008 quelques années plus tard là
cette fois ci il avait réussi à
s'imposer contre l'équipe européenne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la ryder cup c'est aussi l'occasion de
voir des stars mondiales sur les greens
au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
spectateurs auront l'occasion de voir du
beau monde sur le match des célébrités
le mardi 25 septembre prochain huit
personnalités européennes affronteront
huit personnalités américaines dans un
tchad âge de neuf trous par équipes
côté américain on retrouvera notamment
l'acteur et chanteur justin timberlake
grand amateur de golf
le surfeur kelly slater 11 fois champion
du monde ou bien l'ancien secrétaire
d'état américaine condoleezza rice
chez les européens on notera la présence
de l'acteur nord irlandais jamie dornan
du film 50 nuance degré de guy forget le
directeur de roland garros ou encore
l'ancien ballon d'or portugais luis figo
enfin à côté spectateurs le président
français emmanuel macron devraient être
présents tout comme son homologue
américain le président des états unis
donald trump grand fan de golf devrait
faire aussi le déplacement
ça veut ni sa venue sera confirmé au
tout dernier moment
on referme ce magazine des sports par de
la boxe 2i minois seront sur le ring ce
samedi 23 juin pour son cinquième combat
chez les professionnels tony hawk à
originaires de chanteloup les vignes
défiera au palais des sports de la porte
de versailles à paris l'anglais dave
allen 26 ans 1 m 91 13 victoires 2 nuls
et 3 défaites depuis le début de sa
carrière un adversaire à la portée de
tony yoka qui est toujours invaincu à
notre yvelinois combattra également ce
soir la levée rioja ahmed el moussaoui
qui reste sur quatre victoires
consécutives affrontera le russe alexey
cinco devant son public parisien donc
pour un combat en lui rendent un
adversaire qui affiche un bilan de 16
victoires 10 défaites et un nul
cette rencontre pourrait lui permettre
d'engranger des points en vue d'un titre
mondial
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]